I am Nancy ruther associate director of
the Macmillan Center which is the
be home of the happy owner steward of
Luce Hall which is where you're sitting
and we are the Center for International
and area studies at Yale so we look
after keeping the rest of the world and
crucial international global issues in
the curriculum and in the faculty and
students Minds most importantly so one
of the ways we like to work on keeping
international issues very much alive in
educational circles is through our
wonderful peer team the programs in
international education and resources
and I actually have the good fortune of
managing that team which is very easy
because they do it all and I get to
applaud events like this that they
organize and I guess they were in touch
with Judy Freeman from the US Holocaust
Memorial Museum who and they started
cooking up the idea for this conference
for educators to address this awful and
awfully important topic of genocide in
the 20th and the 21st centuries so we
owe a great debt of gratitude to Judy
Freeman and the memorial for a great
deal of the funding and effort to
organize this event along with our own
faculty experts other invited experts in
our own peer team but I think from what
I can tell they have a great set up to
help ensure maximum learning in a very
short time as I understand it this
technique they're going to use verbal
grupa is kind of like the evelyn woods
speed reading method assigned to adult
education it worked very well last
summer with a number of groups so I
suspect you will learn more than you
ever imagined
in a very short time through this method
at least I hope so
and we hope very much that you can take
this back to your own student
and colleagues because this topic
genocide comes in so many lovely guises
so easy to ignore as evil as the
underlying evil that comes in this
nicely painted face all too often so I
wish you all the best in trying to
uncover decode decipher address
understand the terrors and the wonders
that get involved in these unfortunately
global phenomenon so great thanks to
those that have put it together even
greater thanks to those of you who will
take the lessons home to your students
and hopefully prevent or diminish the
prospects for future genocides so with
that I turn it over to my good colleague
Maximo to introduce the important people
the speakers for the evening Thank You
Nancy and we have a wonderful
personality to kick this whole thing off
in the person of Ben Keenan who is the
Whitney crystal professor of history
professor of international and area
studies and director of the genocide
Studies program here at year University
he's the author and co-author of a shelf
full of books of which I will mention
just a few blood and soil a world
history of genocide and extermination
from Sparta to Darfur and I was
published in 2007 and then there is
genocide and resistance in Southeast
Asia documentation denial and justice in
Cambodia and East Timor also published
2007
and then I mentioned this last one how
Paul put's
came to power colonialism nationalism
and communism in Cambodia from 1930 to
1975 and this was published in 1985 and
republished in 2004 Ben is a member of
the editorial boards of vertical Asian
Studies Human Rights Review genocide
studies and Prevention and the Journal
of genocide research he was founding
director of the Cambodian genocide
program here at yield from 1994 to 1999
and convener of the year East Timor
projects from 2000 to 2002 professor
Cairns edited collection conflict and
change in Cambodia won the critical
Asian Studies price for 2002 and was
republished as a book in 2006 he is also
the editor of genocide and democracy in
Cambodia they Herman wrote the United
Nations and the international community
1993 and co-editor of revolution and
it's aftermath in Kampuchea 1983 and the
specter of genocide mass murder in
historical perspective 2003 with this
background please join me to welcome
professor
Thank You max it's a great pleasure to
be here also like to thank Nancy ruther
and also Brian Carter and Judy Freeman
of the Holocaust Memorial Museum the
1948 United Nations Convention on the
prevention and punishment of genocide
defines that crime as quote acts
committed with the intent to destroy in
whole or in part a national racial
ethnic or religious group as such and
these acts include killing members of
the group but also deliberately
inflicting on the group conditions of
life calculated to bring about its
physical destruction in whole or in part
now tonight my goal is threefold
to describe firstly some of the
genocides in world history that meet
this definition second to describe some
of their common recurring themes that
are missing from the legal definition I
just gave you and third to illustrate
some of the new resources available to
students and teachers for teaching about
genocide the Genocide Convention of 1948
focuses on crimes against national
racial ethnic or religious groups and
that correctly makes clear that racial
or religious hatred is an integral part
of genocide along with that though I
want to draw attention to three
lesser-known features that usually
accompany genocide and these are
expansionism agrarianism and cults of
antiquity like racial hatred
expansionism agrarianism and cults of
antiquity are common obsessions of Jena
situs twitch can be detected in advance
genocide or thinking is usually and
recognizably racist rural archaic and
expansionist
now we see here Charlie Chaplin's movie
The Great Dictator a poster for that
movie which illustrates Hitler's desire
to conquer the globe and along with Nazi
hatred of Jews the expansion of Hitler's
regime is fairly well known cults of
agrarianism are lesser known as a common
feature of the genocide or mentality
this photograph of Heinrich Himmler was
taken by his niece in 1935 here we see
Hitler's number two the architect of the
final solution really decked out in
traditional german lederhosen all set to
be photographed in a field near his home
in bavaria in coats of antiquity along
with expansionism and racial hatred and
agrarian ideology cults of antiquity are
a fourth feature of this mindset
genocidal ideology usually seeks
precedence and validation in the past
Hitler praised Arminius Hermann who
annihilated ancient Roman legions as the
first architect of our Liberty when he
urged in 1924 that the new Reich quote
must again set itself on the march along
the road of the Teutonic Knights of old
to obtain by the German sword sod for
the German plow Hitler combined
antiquity with both aggression and
agrarianism he considered Roman history
the best mentor probably for all time he
praised Rome's genocide of Carthage in
146 BC as the execution of the people
through its own deserts the Nazis also
turned to classical Sparta as an ancient
model Hitler recommended that a state
should limit the number allowed to live
and he praised the Spartans for being
capable of such a wise measure of
exposing sickly children to the elements
to die I've just learned
Hitler further remarked that the feeding
of the Roman armies was almost entirely
based on cereals
he said just after invading the Ukraine
and the Soviet Union now he added they
will one day be the greeneries of europe
but only with german agricultural
settlement the slaves are a massive born
slaves he said claiming that under the
German peasant every inch of ground is
zealously exploited nothing is lovelier
than horticulture Germans were more
advanced he said because our ancestors
were all peasants he considered a
healthy peasant class quote a foundation
for a whole nation a solid stock of
small and middle peasants has been at
all times the best protection against
social evils Nazis saw Jews not just as
a subhuman race in their ideology but
also as anti peasants the archetypal
town dwellers anti urban thinking
reinforced the virulent anti-semitism
while we lacked
a legal definition of genocide until the
1940s it goes back at least as far as
the Classical era this is the 13th
century French medieval depiction of the
Roman genocide of Carthage in 146 BC the
instigator of that was Cato the Elder
who was famous as perhaps the first the
author of the first recorded incitement
to genocide Carthage must be destroyed
delenda est Carthago but he was not just
a territorial expansion ax stand
anti-feminist sense or he was Kate or
the sense Cato the sense or but he was
also an agrarian astute and to protect
ancient Roman rural values against
mercantile threats like Carthage it is
true that to obtain money by trade is
sometimes more profitable work not so
hazardous he wrote and likewise
money-lending if it were as honourable
our ancestors held this view their
praise took this form good farmer and
good settler one so praised was thought
to have received the greatest comment
Cato wrote in his book on agriculture it
is from the farming class he went on
that the bravest men and the sturdiest
soldiers come their calling is most
highly respected medieval thinking about
war was less genocidal this medieval
depiction of the fall of Carthage looks
more like a medieval siege than a
classical genocide but medieval look
look medieval look backwards changed
dramatically in early modern Europe
first with the Renaissance rediscovery
of classical texts providing much more
horrendous descriptions of what had
happened to Carthage and second with the
onset of European expansion and
imperialism at the beginning of the
world said a Portuguese Jesuit in 1559
all was homicide it was in the 16th
century that many Europeans began
looking to ancient precedents even for
genocide a phenomenon that became more
frequent with European expansion in 1492
and afterwards in post medieval early
modern culture the story of Carthage now
became much better known and more
homicidally depicted just to contrast
this is a 17th century depiction of a
biblical genocide of Joshua against the
amorite s' very different and more
blood-curdling depiction than in
medieval periods at the same time
European and imperial and territorial
conquests of most of the globe involve
pastoral or agrarian romanticism as well
as both genocide and anti-semitism
supposedly justified by classical and
biblical antiquity conquerors turned to
ancient genocides for precedence when
the Spanish built their empire in the
new world they looked to Rome's
expansion to justify their own estimates
of the native population of the island
of
span Yola distributed among these five
kingdoms in 1492 range from 500,000 or
so by 1514 just 32,000 Indians survived
over 90% of the Islanders perished in 22
years also a similar catastrophe was the
result in Mexico of cortezes conquests
there in the early 16th century and this
is scenes of that barbarity depicted by
the victims later in the sixteenth
century as the end as the early modern
English sought their own conquests they
self-consciously took on the mantle of
Roman imperialism to justify their
expansion in 1570 and 71 a group of
Elizabethan gentlemen met frequently in
London to discuss classical Roman
military strategy at the home of Sir
Thomas Smith the Smiths and their
associate Gabriel Harvey used classical
texts as handbooks for colonizing Oster
in Ireland another participant in these
classical discussions was Sir Humphrey
Gilbert who would spent years fighting
in Ireland and he also wrote in
admiration of ancient Rome's supremacy
he even shared Cato's rage against
domestic and cultural threats as well as
foreign enemies these Elizabeth and
Knights saw Island as Cato had Carthage
and here is one of them another member
of this circle who left for Ireland in
1580 Sir Arthur grade to Wilton along
with edmund spenser the famous writer
the poet Spenser wrote a Latin poem
calling Gabriel Harvey the great Kato of
our era
Harvey wrote back that your great Cato's
and our little Cato's make such a
buzzing and ringing in my head
Spencer was in Ireland with gray in
November 1580 when Sir Arthur Greater
Wilton depicted on the right here
ordered his troops to carry out the
massacre of 600
disarmed surrendered papal troops gray
reported to Elizabeth the first I put in
certain bands who straight fell to
execution there were 600 slain and this
sketch is a wood cut from a 1581
pamphlet which asserted that the papal
troops had received their just desserts
incited by a blasphemous anti-christian
prelate the Pope potent as they were
classical precedent and religious
bigotry were not the sole justifications
for the English slaughter in Ireland
contributing to growing ethnic animosity
was the view of many English settlers
that the Irish were poor farmers they
couldn't cultivate the land colonial
propagandists described Islanders
uncultivated or even uninhabited because
it wasn't cultivated one advised
colonists to bring seed and implements
as if they should imagine to find
nothing here but earth and indeed little
else shall they find a different kind of
agrarian fetish was evident across the
world
a decade later during Japan's invasions
of Korea in the 1590s this is a painting
of Kyoto early in the 17th century not
long afterwards kill Koreans one by one
and empty the country whether it was the
order of the Japanese ruler Hideyoshi he
urged his forces to punish the Koreans
without leaving a thing behind he
rewarded his soldiers for each Korean
they put out of action documented by
their presentation of the severed noses
of their victims the noses were then
sent pickled in barrels to Kyoto where
Hideyoshi built this mound in the center
right there the green mound with the
monument on the top is known as the
mimizuku or ear mound supposedly
containing the Buried ears and noses of
the victims ears were not their only
content so Japanese generals war memoirs
testified to the burial of 185,000
Korean and 29,000 Chinese heads
along with this external expansionism
aimed at the conquest of China as well
as Korea Hideyoshi's domestic policy was
decidedly agrarian Japanese farmers had
to remain in their place as a
subservient peasantry otherwise the
fields would not be cultivated Hideyoshi
feared his policy ensured that quote the
farmers will be saved in this life
needless to say and in the life to come
should any farmer abandoning his fields
go into trade or wage labour that person
needless to say and all in his village
shall be brought to judgment back in the
Atlantic England's conquest of Ireland
had set a precedent for North America
when Humphrey Gilbert went down with his
ship in the Atlantic in 1583 his
half-brother Sir Walter Raleigh took his
place our land is full their land is
empty one colonist wrote of the Indians
in 1622 they are few and do but run over
the grass as do also the foxes and the
wild beasts in this view Indians whose
corn fed the newcomers in Massachusetts
supposedly had no faculty to use either
the land or the commodities of it so it
is lawful now to take a land which none
euzeth but Native Americans contested
the seizure of their land and after
clashes in 1637 here in Connecticut
Massachusetts declared war on the Pequot
Indians settlers in Hartford also
declared an offensive war Boston branded
the Pequots and all other Indians as a
common enemy they surrounded the Pequot
village at West mystic and in an hour
and something just over one hour burned
to death the entire population inside
about 600 or 700 Pequot Indians and
their families this is a sketch from
1638 by one of the participants John
Underhill which shows
ninety-eight lodges all on fire the
English lost two dead in in this attack
thus was God seen John Mason the leader
added burning them up in the fire of his
wrath and dunking the ground with their
flesh
in other words manuring the ground
emphasizing again the connection between
genocide and the fetish of cultivation
the Indian allies of the English who
were in the outer ring as you can see
with the English forces on the inside
and surrounding the fort the Indian
allies who were Narragansetts thought
that this finding method was too furious
and sliced too many men they said John
Underhill wrestled with the implications
of the massacre it may be demanded why
should you be so furious as some have
said should not Christians have more
mercy and compassion but he answered by
appealing to ancient biblical precedent
I would refer you to David's war he
wrote sometimes the scripture declare if
women and children must perish with
their parents we had sufficient light
from the Word of God for our proceedings
here is a portrait of the site in 1879
on the hill above the Mystic River still
empty colonial massacres of indigenous
peoples were numerous sometimes
genocidal this map shows just a few
selected cases one of the major
developments of world history is the
very rapid occupation by European
settlers of to almost entire continents
North America and Australia in the 19th
century the extermination of the
Tasmanian Aborigines all four thousand
of whom died during British settlement
in the 19th century is well known but
their tribal names shown on this 1998
map are rarely mentioned yet Tasmania
was no exception around 1800 the
Australian mainland itself was home to
over 700 Aboriginal communities each
with its own language
over the next century most of these
ethnic groups and their languages also
disappeared in the violent conquest of
the continent in 1886 an Australian
artist depicted the fate of Aborigines
this way the two top sketches are
inaccurate in fact White's didn't
disembark shooting from their ships nor
did Aborigines spear missionaries but
White's did often kill Aborigines to
protect their investment in pastoral
stock mostly sheep many more blacks died
of diseases or hunger as their native
game the Kangaroos retreated at the
advance of white farmers in both
Tasmania and the mainland white settlers
argued that the native peoples did not
cultivate the land and therefore could
not own it even White's who did
recognize Aborigines as owners of the
land could hardly imagine them actually
occupying it here is a map drawn by the
founder of Melbourne in Australia in
1835 John Batman showing land that he
considered he'd bought from Aborigines
it's entitled attractive countries ceded
by the native Chiefs of southern
Australia to John Batman the Chiefs are
unnamed and their people appear nowhere
on the map which is largely empty except
perhaps you can read for descriptions of
its emptiness the word open appears on
it six times
combined four times with extensive
extensive open plains as far as the eye
can reach to the westwards open an
extensive country and so on now if John
Batman could have seen or imagined more
Aborigines or recognized their land use
the open plains across what became the
state of Victoria might have looked more
like this I just wanted to our attention
to the Kurenai people of Gippsland that
region of Victoria in the eastern part
of the map instead by 1858 battements
map of the Melbourne area resembled this
a solid grid of settlement displacing
Aboriginal occupants the Kearney region
was now called Gippsland
in this 1858 map just 23 years after
battements Treaty of 1835 in less than a
quarter of a century the 2,000 or more
Kern I people had almost disappeared
from hunger disease and massacres their
homes had acquired classical names like
the Acheron river and the Rubicon it
took another 30 years to retrospectively
map the five Kern I tribes and clans and
their neighboring Aboriginal tribe the
same era saw another catastrophe in
California which might have looked
something like this at the onset of u.s.
rule in 1846 from then until 1874 in
northern California federal troops state
government and local militias and bounty
hunters all conducted repeated massacres
of Indian populations including some on
this map for instance the Yuki and
Tolliver many linguistic groups vanished
the San Francisco Bulletin commented in
1860 even the record of Spanish
butcheries in Mexico and Peru has
nothing so diabolical in the destruction
of Indians elsewhere a pastoral romance
accentuated this pervasive agrarianism
along with the exigencies of conquest
General George Armstrong Custer is shown
in this map somewhere that's his wagon
train going through the Black Hills of
Dakota in 1874 Custer found there what
the New York Tribune called an Eden in
the sky without the forbidden fruit this
photograph by William Illingworth shows
paradise in July 1874 Custer
wrote every step of our March that day
was amidst flowers of the most exquisite
colors and perfume so luxuriant and
growth were they that men plucked them
without dismantling from the saddle it
was a strange sight to glance back at
the advancing columns of cavalry and
behold the men with beautiful bouquets
in their hands while the headgear of
their horses
was decorated with wreaths of flowers
fit to crown a queen of may Custer added
the soil is that of a rich garden
Nature has done so much to prepare homes
for husbandmen the New York world
proclaimed an agricultural and pastoral
paradise a Chicago reporter wrote that
the Indian will never make any use of
the rich soil that has been waiting
centuries to be utilized so it would not
be robbing him to deprive him of it
accompanying this agrarian and pastoral
romance was the model from antiquity the
New York Tribune reporter wondered did
Julius Caesar have such a wagon train as
the soldiers pitched camp the he
reported they asked their commander how
many miles today just as Xenophon was
asked ultimately the conquest of the
North American continent became a
triumph of civilization over
pastoralists
and its art reflected that grandeur here
we see an eclectic combination of the
classical the national the indigenous
and the pastoral in the Philadelphia
Washington Monument despite two
millennia of genocides many people think
of that crime as a 20th century
phenomenon this is in part because new
technology and communications now made
genocide even more efficient and
mechanized the first non colonial
genocide of the 20th century was the
Armenian catastrophe at the hands of the
Young Turks regime of the Ottoman Empire
during World War one it started in early
1915 when hundreds of Armenians were
rounded up and hanged in the streets of
Constantinople before beginning the
genocide 'el deportation of the
Armenians to the desert in which perhaps
a million died or were murdered enroute
in turn the Armenian case became a model
for other genocides of the 20th century
after all its perpetrators had got away
with mass murder who today speaks of the
Armenians Hitler asked in 1939 this was
the era of the rise
and fall of fascism and communism for
new totalitarian party states
propounding scientific race or class
ideologies entire groups became inimical
or expendable the Communist Giants
Stalin's USSR and Mao's China pursued
mass killing of domestic political
enemies and social classes they were a
bit less preoccupied with racial
categories or territorial expansion ISM
and not at all with historical antiquity
Stalin unlike Mao harbored no hint of
agrarian idealism either but despite
these important exceptions the major
themes of previous eras racial and
religious hatreds fetishes with history
and agriculture and territorial
expansion ISM persisted in most of the
cases in what has been called the
century of genocide just past this
photograph shows how Tov Hitler on the
right and Hermann Goering on the left at
Hitler's Mountain Home House Birkenfeld
in the Bavarian Alps Ignatius Farah
published this photo in Homes and
Gardens November 1938 he described what
he called this quote sunny subalpine
home hundreds of miles from Berlin's
uproar said amid an unsophisticated
peasantry of Carver's and hunters of the
squire of Aachen felt Hitler wrote
Pharaoh wrote it is over twelve years
since Herr Hitler fixed on the site of
his one and only home here in the early
days Hitler's widowed sister kept house
for him on a peasant scale sometimes
when state affairs are over the squire
himself attended by some of his guests
will stroll through the woods into the
Hamlet's above and below their rustics
sit at cottage doors carving trinkets
and toys and wood ivory and bone throwin
Goebbels and Goering in dainty Bavarian
dress arranged dances and folk songs
here is Himmler in the fall of 1942
inspecting cotton fields in Ukraine the
results of this agrarian and racial Nazi
ideology and action
well known a Jewish prisoner in
Auschwitz photographed with her head
held in a bracket an open mass grave
with thousands of Jews in Ukraine 1942
at Nazi propaganda poster in Ukraine the
collective farm system has come to an
end every hard-working peasant will get
land of his own of course this isn't
what happened but it was an integral
part of Nazi propaganda so was this this
is a the cover of an SS magazine
February 1942 Foulke and raza race and
people people in race idealizing a
German farmer in Ukraine across the
other side of the world the Japanese
were expanding into China and this is a
1938 Pro Japanese cartoon emphasizing
the destruction of biological pests that
is the Communists and the Chinese
warlords in at the hands of the Japanese
who represented the rising East Pol
Pot's Khmer Rouge regime in Cambodia
during the late 1970s combined Stalinist
communism with racism and agrarian
idealism and also a cult of antiquity
but not of Rome
this is Angkor Wat centre of the
medieval Khmer Empire built between 1080
and 1150 Pol Pot called himself the
original Khmer and spun a national
narrative of Cambodia's lost glory since
the era of Angkor in that story the
command nation had lost lands lost to
encroachments on Cambodia by Vietnamese
from the east and Thais from the West
this is a satellite image of Cambodia
this is an Cambodian identity card of a
Vietnamese resident of Cambodia in the
1950s Cambodia did not grant citizenship
to its ethnic Vietnamese minority and
they and other minorities suffered
genocide under Pol Pot's regime in the
late 1970s one of even Cambodians of the
majority Khmer group were often targeted
with the label Khmer bodies with
Vietnamese minds the midnight in the
mid-1960s and particularly from 1970 the
Vietnam War had spilled over into
Cambodia and the forces of Pol Pot and
the xenophobic Khmer Rouge communists
whom he led grew under US bombardment
these are the sites that were bombed
about 2.7 million tons of u.s. bombs
were dropped on Cambodia between 1965
and 73 and in that period particularly
at the height of the bombing from 1970
to 1973 the Khmer Rouge forces grew from
five thousand to over two hundred
thousand largely because of their
ability to recruit because of peasant
resentment at the destruction and death
wrought by the bombing the Khmer Rouge
leaders envisioned an agrarian society
free of urban contaminations when they
took the capital in April 1975 they
immediately evacuated its two million
residents into the countryside blew up
the National Bank this is the photo I
took in 1975 this is a photo I took in
1980 it still hadn't been repaired five
years later they also abolished money
and launched attacks into communist
Vietnam and four years later 1.7 million
Cambodians had died a fifth of the
population meanwhile in 1976 the Khmer
Rouge
turned up Phnom Penh High School in to
s21 the secret central prison and
extermination center this is a 1980
photograph of - whirl at s21 the Khmer
Rouge jailers photographed four thousand
prisoners and killed fourteen thousand
only seven survived in 1979 when the
regime fell to a retaliatory Vietnamese
invasion here is another prisoner of the
Khmer Rouge photograph with his head
held in a bracket recalling the Jewish
prisoner of the Nazis we saw earlier
this is the excavation of the graves of
the prisoners in September 1980 the site
is now a memorial with skulls stored
behind glass walls in a Buddhist stupa
these are memorials to the victims in
Vietnam of Khmer Rouge cross-border
raids in which tens of thousands of
Vietnamese farmers some of them ethnic
Cambodians most of them ethnic
Vietnamese were slaughtered by Khmer
Rouge forces crossing the border there's
another memorial in Vietnam to a
massacre on March 14th 1978 a 1978
Vietnamese cartoon takes up the issue of
antiquity as well this shows the ancient
Chinese emperor qin jeff Wandy who was
famous for burning the books and you can
see the Great Wall of China in the
background and and was also famous as a
very repressive ruler he's telling the
Khmer Rouge you are doing a very good
job following my example piling up
skulls and burning books as well not
long ago a Thai actress was reported in
Cambodia claiming that Angkor Wat
belonged to Thailand she denies saying
any such thing but Thais have
occasionally said that in the past and
this provoked a very violent reaction in
Cambodia in which Thai businesses and
hotels were trashed and even the Thai
Embassy
meanwhile across the South China Sea and
East Timor Indonesia invaded that
territory this is a picture photographs
taken just before the Indonesian of
invasion of East Timor in 1975 half of
the island was already part of Indonesia
and the Indonesians expanded into East
Timor but were unable to crush East
Timor its resistance for during a 24
year occupation until the UN held a
plebiscite on independence and this
satellite photograph was taken a couple
of weeks later not long after the vote
was announced by the UN that 79% of
temari's
had voted for independence from
Indonesia the Indonesian troops
responded by burning down 80% of the
buildings in the country and killing
more than a thousand people and the
satellite went over on September 8th
1999 you can see that small island
towards the top if you look down from
their south towards the coast you'll see
this particular area the capital of
Dilli and if you zoom in the
high-resolution satellite image actually
shows the black plumes of smoke pouring
out of the city of Dilli which had been
set on fire by the retreating
Indonesians meanwhile in the 1980s
another military dictatorship in
Guatemala conducted a counterinsurgency
genocide of Mayan Indian groups in an
age-old themed Guatemalan regime urged
survivors to become new farmers we have
a satellite image of part of the
homeland of the Mayan Indian group's
majority in Guatemala the ischial
triangle this was work done by Russel
shimmer who's here tonight and Adam
Jones as well and it shows the
deforestation of an area where Mayan
groups were subjected to genocide
scorched earth tactics the red splotches
that you can see there surrounding the
shield triangle represent areas
deforested between 1789 1979 in 1986 the
covering the height of the genocide from
81 to 83 the Rwandan genocide in 1994
came complete with its own cult of
racism and antiquity this is an ID card
that Tutsis were forced to carry in
Rwanda from the 1950s of 90 since the
1930s but these were used to round up
Tutsis during the 1994 genocide one of
the people now serving a jail term for
genocide is a historian named Ferdinand
nahi mana that's him there on the left
that he drew this map in 1983 of the
ancient kingdoms of Rwanda he saw these
Hutu principalities in the northwest of
Rwanda as the real pure Rwanda before
the interloping Tutsis arrived
supposedly from Abyssinia in the 16th
century before that Hutu ideologues
claimed that the Hutu people and other
ethnic groups were living peacefully as
farmers and it was only the disruption
of rwanda by arrival of Tutsi immigrants
in early modern times that was the
course of ethnic conflict in Rwanda
here is a satellite image of
post-genocide Rwanda the blue dots
represent mass graves from the 1994
genocide the red dots represent
memorials to the victims and the green
dots represent sites of resistance
particularly over in the west near Lake
kevo near a place called byssus Arrow
Hill where some Tutsi victims held out
in the forest in resistance against the
Hutu power killers you can see that on
the left near the lake this is just
zeroing in again the red splotches
represent areas where there has been the
vegetation removed and if we zoom in a
bit closer again those two green circles
represent sites of resistance from the
map I showed you earlier and you can see
the red pixels and splotches showing
deforestation where the victims were
chased down by the scorched earth
tactics of the killers cutting down the
trees in order to destroy the resistance
or the people taking shelter in in the
forest unfortunately even though the
United Nations in 2004 on the 10th
anniversary apologized to the Rwandan
people and hoped to do better and also
President Clinton made a similar apology
as well
at this very 10th anniversary ceremony
the genocide in Darfur had already begun
this is a 2004 image of destruction in
one part of Darfur here is a more recent
image of a place on the right identified
by the u.s. Holocaust Memorial regime's
excellent report called crisis in Darfur
not far away from a completely undamaged
village compound but I want to show a
more general
picture of West Darfur which is the
result of more work done by Russell
shimmer very recently you know I've just
wanted to share this with you because it
will be on the website of the genocide
studies program may be useful for
students to use some of this material
but this shows change in vegetation
after the beginning of the outbreak of
the genocide in Darfur in 2003 where
where it really began by the time of the
next year you can see there are large
splotches of blue which suggest decrease
in vegetation which is probably a result
of the people being killed or driven out
and the land not being cultivated but
over time we get a different feature
also a result of the people being killed
or driven out which is an increase a bit
later in vegetation because the
livestock have also been driven out and
the wild plants are coming back and the
biomass is now going in increasing
enormous Li and so from the initial
decrease we have an enormous increase in
the amount of vegetation but it's mostly
a result of both the people and the
animals being emptied and of course you
can correlate that with the Centers of
destruction of the militias who have
destroyed so many of the villages and
stolen so much of the livestock of the
people of Darfur
so for telltale characteristic of
genocide have recurred regularly since
the 15th century at least and even in
ancient times the preoccupation of
perpetrators with race antiquity
agriculture and expansion the early
modern rediscovery of Rome's destruction
of Carthage provoked repeated
comparisons with indigenous victims of
contemporary cases in colonial Ireland
and Mexico commentators speculated that
the hapless indigenous were actually
descended from surviving Carthaginians
dispersed across the world a British
official in the Scottish Highlands in
1692 wrote about them
clan delenda est Carthago Carthage must
be destroyed
quoting Cato directly as expansionism
escalated the myth of an untouched empty
land usually played a key role in
spurring the displacement and
destruction of its actual inhabitants so
did the settler fetish for cultivation
of that land agricultural metaphors
easily expressed mass murder of target
groups a Spanish settler in 16th century
Mexico talked of using Indian blood to
irrigate his fields while British and
German settlers in Australia threatened
to use the bodies of Aborigines for
fertilizer the Khmer Rouge administered
that very fate they actually did that to
Cambodian city dwellers even as
urbanization spread over the globe in
the 20th century a violent form of
agrarianism still flourished through its
final decades from Eastern Europe to
Southeast Asia from Central America to
Central Africa genocidal regimes across
the political spectrum that massacred
ethnic enemies also sponsored
agriculturalists and settlers employing
the same terms in a variety of
vocabularies it's amazing to track the
genocidal regimes of various different
political hues using the same term model
farmers in their different languages to
describe what was necessary to replace
victims fetishes of biological purity
and contamination have also strengthened
the racism and violence that promote
genocide in Ireland in 1580 Lord Arthur
Greater Wilton whom you saw before
inform Queen Elizabeth that Catholicism
was a disease a canker never receiving
cure without corrosive medicines in 1641
another English commander Sir Charles
could justified his order to kill not
only Irish men and women but also
children more than a span long with the
metaphor kill the nits and you will have
no lice in the 19th century that slogan
reemerged in both the Australian outback
and the American West as a common call
to Massacre in
millions and Aborigines nits grow into
lice the Nazis too likened Jews to lice
while al-qaeda in Iraq today targets
Iraq's Shia community as the locusts
where the disease lies quote-unquote the
cure and prevention of the crime of
genocide must lie at least in part in
the diagnosis of it's recurring causes
and symptoms despite all these
catastrophes the 16th century Portuguese
Jesuit was wrong or was not homicide at
or since the beginning of the world as
he put it
not even in early modern and the modern
world large historical processes made it
more likely but genocide is always the
result of decisions made by individuals
usually very few acting conspiratorial
II who think in certain similar ways
disgust them and set about putting those
views into action others and just about
every case this is true others oppose
them genocide is not inherent in human
history but it is recognizable there
often it is detectable in advance it can
be seen coming and we have to recognize
it
we have time for questions or comments
right
a growing ism is a kind of ideal
response to urbanization I think when
Cato in ancient Rome talked about the
farmers being the real Romans he was
complaining about city people and their
contamination by promiscuous Greek
values and education and of course
getting out of control he would complain
about women grouping together in large
numbers and and trying to have a say in
politics in many ways agrarian ISM is is
not so much an idealization of a real
agricultural community it's more a
reaction against urbanization and
modernity and racism is something quite
similar I see them as philosophically
related that they're both idealist
completely divorced from material
reality but of course with the right
military power an organizational skill
racism can be forcefully imposed on a
community and so can an agrarian romance
and I would add that agrarianism is
strengthened by the other factor I
mentioned which is expansionism that
often the expansionist imperative is
justified by the idea that the people
living there don't conquer the land but
of course it can be not just people who
are living there it can be you know
indigenous people who are pastoralists
or hunter-gatherers or real farmers who
are both in Australia and in North
America when Aboriginal isaw Cherokees
and others did actually found quite
competitively
it wasn't acknowledged that that's what
they were doing though and they were
still deported from their land in
Australia as late as the 1920s
Aborigines who were farming corn at the
mouths of rivers in northern New South
Wales were just driven off the
and it was continued to be said that
they were not real farmers and so that
was a growing innocent function not only
as an idealistic partner to racism but
also as an excuse for expansionism well
I would say that modernist agrarianism
is a reaction to modernity it goes along
with it so the more modernity you have
the more you are likely to have agrarian
reaction to it and of course the Nazis
needed a massive military machine to
conquer the territories and exterminate
the people that they did but if you look
at the people who actually implemented
the Holocaust specifically Himmler and
the authors of the general plan us the
general plan east who talked about not
only massacring six million Jews but
millions of other people and deporting
31 million slaves and other inhabitants
of Eastern Europe those people sure they
they were the authors of of modern
military purposes but they also were
romantic agrarians in particular Himmler
I think the architect of the Holocaust
is the best example of that there are
people back in Berlin like Speer for
instance who didn't really represent
that so much and there are others I
think in in all of the minds of the of
these genocide perpetrators there is a
continuing tension between the vision of
the primeval ethnic pristine past which
is an agrarian society of only of
Germans with no Jews and at the same
time the need
modern machinery to implement that
creative attention which is difficult to
prise apart re odd
ideologically I think what's happening
in Kenya at the moment is a tragic case
of communal massacres between ethnic
groups of course there was a similar
event in Bombay Mumbai and Gujarat in
nineteen in 2002 in which Muslims and
Hindus after Muslims supposedly burnt a
train Hindu mobs massacred them but they
did that with a lot of state sponsorship
behind the scenes and but I I think it
is possible to have this communal
massacres which are more spontaneous and
I think it may be that behind the census
is a number of a group of political
operatives who see benefit to be gained
from this communal conflict and will
probably know that before too long but
it also may may result in a more
organized genocidal campaign I think we
have to be very watchful in the case of
of Kenya there is the possibility of
genocide or massacres happening in out
of spontaneous ethnic resentment but
they usually don't last for a long
period of time and if they do it's
usually because there were actors
conspiring behind the scenes
yes in my book blood and soil I have a
chapter on colonial genocides in Africa
and that's one of the main ones the
Herero people were subjected to genocide
by German colonists including the father
of him and Goering Heinrich Goering was
one of the first German governors of
Southwest Africa the German colony and
others who later played a role in the
Holocaust were active in that first
decade of the 20th century in the
genocide of the Herero and nama people
in the 1907 I said the first non
colonial genocide Armenia is usually
called the first genocide of the 20th
century and it's certainly a much larger
case than the Herero case but I think
the Herero case is that the first
genocide of a 20th century
yes I think you're quite right yeah I
think there's an extraneous influence in
Mao originally adopted from an even more
violent predecessor called pump I in the
1920s who developed this idea of the of
the peasant revolution in China but but
of course there was also the influence
of Stalinism which was not at all
agrarian and in fact crushed the
peasantry under the policy of building
up the cities and industrialization
yeah I think there were other factors
too in the Soviet Chinese split
including Chinese nationalism and Soviet
sort of domination or attempts to
dominate the Chinese Communist Party but
I think there's a lot to it that these
revolutions went different ways are much
more industrial bias in the in the
Soviet case and at least in the Cultural
Revolution as strong romanticization of
the rural areas including driving
intellectuals out into the countryside
to see what it was like to be a peasant
but of course the main victims of now
and were peasants who starve to death in
the Great Leap Forward of the late 1950s
yeah
yes I'm don't know very much about that
particular case that by Afrin case so I
probably shouldn't guess at where it
might work might fit or whether it was a
genocide of course we I haven't talked
much today about another crime of
extermination which is also legally
enshrined as a crime against humanity
and it doesn't require as much legal
proof for instance that with the
extermination doesn't require proof of
the intent to destroy as well as the
acts such as killing members of the
group which genocide requires so many of
the cases that border on genocide would
be quite clearly extermination